each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'd like to talk about bringing together
multiple small models of health and they
need to open them up some experiences we
have with doing this in Manchester
particularly those experiences of
microsoft research and to show you why I
think a lot of these science is
applicable not just to science but to
health care in pragmatic aspects so
three areas i'd like to give up what's
the problem we're looking at well very
simply it's late fragmented healthcare
what's the target that I'm aiming for
I'm aiming for a target of usefully
complex models of health which are
bigger models and the vehicle that I'll
describe is what we call ELab which cuts
across a number of projects but it's
basically the open union of data methods
and people to support largest scientific
insights but more timely and specific
and useful decision making in healthcare
ask yourselves do you have health care
okay lots of debates at the moment in
the US about health care what do you
have is it health care well for
thousands of years we've been developing
a great rescue system we have great
sickness cap have health care that's
perceived around the clinical model our
resource use is focused on late stage of
disease when we need rescuing and on
humane basis of course we must dash in
and rescue the ill but to do this we've
had to do something in knowledge
management which is to specialize to
optimize our resources for that late
stage rescue but wider health about
disease when you may not have illness
but you have underlying disease you have
risks the resource there proportional to
the disease and risk has a very
different optimization there you need to
generalize not specialized to optimize
so one is reactive
the other is proactive so how have we
done after 5,000 years since Epocrates
of developing health care how have we
really done a lot celebrated around
mobile technologies high-tech medicine
integrating that into personal health
records but how do we reach back to some
of the root causes let's take a life
course view okay you're born and your
journey of your genes through your
epigenetic environment as little points
of no return well they deferentially the
resulting physiology and your
environment has cumulative effects so
you're losing potential healthy life
years and you eventually die let's
consider hip fracture hip fracture is a
catastrophic event for many elderly
people if this person fractures a hip
here the amount of healthy life year
lost is enormous the societal costs the
opportunity cost is a large proportion
of healthcare usage for fairly small
resource we could probably delay that
and indeed structured exercise programs
have a thirty five percent relative risk
reduction which is more effective than
some of our most effective medicines
statins top out at about thirty one
percent so important stuff for society
we have a false dichotomy we have over
here public health prevention well-being
in its own little bubble and over here
high-tech medicine with lots of resource
and lots of political debate this
represents the life of a person the life
course of a person and this the life of
a parliament quite naturally any done
instability to a health care system is a
political difficulty but we need to
build models if we're to make health
care more effective and affordable back
to how does it wire together of early
stages of disease and that's why I need
big models because we can't afford this
system
esides can help I believe and here we
need to deal with data flooded
healthcare which is what we have at the
moment and turn it into data intensive
healthcare big gaps big fragments
between self care clinical care primary
care secondary care hospital a hospital
be huge ravines a communication that
leads to medical error and medical
inefficiency what have we done to cross
those gaps or in the past 20 years
there's been a big knowledge management
exercise to create integrated care
pathways but those integrated care
pathways go down those clinical silos
okay I said we specialize to optimize in
late-stage care so we have highly
specialist clinical care pathways on
specific diseases developed by specific
disciplines we do not have models that
cut across different care pathways but
the patient presenting with type 2
diabetes chronic kidney disease maybe
arthritis maybe coronary heart disease
is a model across those different care
pathways we do not have those models
across the care pathways in routine
clinical practice so where do we want to
be we don't want to be with health
records and individual integrated care
pathways managed by clinical silos we
want to have an integrated model the
maximum synthesis the maximum int
information utility is not health record
it wouldn't look like a health record
the union of all of the useful bits of
information about what's happened to
that person how they vary according to
the average person and how they
responded to treatment is much more like
an avatar so I think future health
record debates at the moment lack a
discussion of models models beyond
individual care models a population
health care I'm a public health doctor
so I pull in projects that try to bring
the structure from evidence papers in
one part of an evidence base with papers
in another so the policymakers can come
together and say well what if we invest
in statins down here
what bang are we going to get from book
compared with investing in physical
activity and earlier stage interventions
very complex synthesis of evidence but
there is a lot of structure to you can
add and a lot of quantitative modeling
to be done to brought bring together
existing health evidence to optimize our
healthcare systems this is particularly
important at times of erk economic
austerity this is some work we're doing
a medical research council across a
number of different disease areas so
this has produced some software for that
what if scenario planning the software
has to be available to interact with the
decision maker it's not enough to
produce a report for an option appraisal
meeting in a health paying organization
or in the UK and Health Authority
Primary Care Trust but what if scenarios
what if we turn up the dial of the
statins would have returned up the
smoking cessation playable models that
combine the evidence at the point of
decision making so that needs a platform
for both opening the evidence and
building bigger models that can
influence those decisions many
disciplines coming together the model I
showed you before was a synthesis of not
owning the natural history of disease
you can see progression of disease down
here but it's also a map of how we wire
together our services so you're building
grasps across disciplines as well as
across papers but have we got the
evidence if this represents all we could
know about how an individual or a
population would respond to treatment
this is what's in the vast but in
context this is the relevant relative
size of the evidence base that and this
is what we're missing because clinical
trials are done in patients usually who
don't have other diseases than the one
on the study not they're not done in
women of childbearing age
a lot of the medications so when a
medication in particular is released
there is a natural experiment taking
place of healthcare so how are we going
to extract those natural experiments and
build a bigger model of care there are
many initiatives to pull together data
but do we really want to create a great
big tomb of data oh it just gathers
digital dust the different tribes
feeding in their data to the tool
without interacting with the data don't
provide rich can text your metadata
because they're not part of the model so
we're not getting the metadata we need
for the better models so one of our
projects a large-scale building of a
system to extract research ready data
from health healthcare records is
assembling the data that we have but
allowing the transform data to be paid
played back to the people who collect
the data so we're dealing with this data
flood by being very interactive with the
people at the frontline of healthcare
which is quite difficult in quite messy
but constantly I'm reminded the
contextual expertise is the bottleneck
very few people actually transforming
data and questioning the data and
whether we need to capture more this is
typically what we're doing creating an e
lab in the health service to bring data
methods and people together an enormous
effort is going into the issues of
privacy protection and making sure there
isn't deductive disclosure of anything
that leaves the firewall of healthcare
or clinical information governance so
that a patient isn't maliciously or
accidentally identified when they don't
need to be that is created anonymized
repositories that consist of every
transaction taking place in the cloud of
care ranging from hospitals general
practices out into the community which
is opticians pharmacy and demographic
data and I believe this is where you
should put a lot of the life science
effort when you
really clean phenotype because a very
messy world out there in routine care so
mounting some of these studies in here
has proven very useful what the service
need not to be that donkey hanging aloft
is a sense making layer so we have a lot
of effort to build statistical and
visualization software on top of
anonymized repositories for defined
populations whether people observing the
patterns in the data also observe the
population so what happens when you do
that this is an audit question that was
asked of me by a colleague who looks
after people with type 2 diabetes and
obesity on the vertical axis is the red
blood cell concentration so people down
here are anemic and feeling tired and
listless these people have type 2
diabetes on this axis is their kidney
function estimated the Maryland
filtration rate imputed so from from
their creatinine blood tests that are
done regularly their age and sex and
optionally their ethnicity if it was
well coded just by pulling the data
together we found that this drop-off
point as kidneys are shrinking and not
sending enough signal to the bone marrow
to produce more red blood cells was much
earlier than in the Natural History than
was previously thought so there was much
more of an alert that we should be
looking out for nemia the practical side
the audit loot was closed by changing
test ordering in this hospital
information system but this is quite an
important paper that makes us ask
questions as to why were they sensitive
to anemia in type 2 diabetics we
couldn't have done this unless we
captured some more metadata it was a
noisy signal to begin with then the
chemical pathologist came along and said
well I changed the lab assay halfway
through your data capture period for
creatinine which means we had to use a
different formula to derive this
statistic here if this data have been
derived from one of those big data tombs
without the metadata about the lab hace
we wouldn't have got a clear picture
this is to stress the importance of
playing this back models that p
interact with at the front line so to
get a mandate to do that amount of
playback we need to be very clear about
how the data was used the provenance the
audit the when what were why and the
context so this brings us to a concept
of packaging together the processes of
the data on the anonymized repositories
which we call work objects if you
consider this is what's done now all
around the world some very expensive
initiatives but they extract data from
health agencies put them into a research
agency and build a research governance
around them so they put security round
here they put ethics round here but if
you can mount you make the software move
into the place where the data is being
observed then you've triple insulated in
terms of governance this is more ethical
this is more secure now this is why
we're building our real abs in the field
of healthcare very practical things
recruiting people for clinical trials if
over here you've got the anonymized side
of integrated healthcare data and these
people are I sciency sort of
competencies where they're very good at
extracting the right data in the right
way and demanding the right sort of
metadata so the queries are optimized
here the data transformations are
optimized but we build software to
preserve this clinical care boundary so
in this case query to identify people
eligible to participate in a clinical
trial delivered through secure email to
clinician it's only the clinician who
can see the identities of the
individuals this is the anonymized side
but the query click run back through to
database but using this particular query
so this individual can recruit as
patients thereby preserving consent for
consent practical things that it gets us
to the frontline then we have to scale
up to work across multiple localities to
get bigger studies there are 10
developers currently working on build
that infrastructure it's based on two
streams of functionality a resource bus
for transforming the data and a work
object bus for describing storing
transferring managing those packages of
processed data this is different just to
a workflow view of e science is the
wrote the research object in a clinical
setting might have to have special audit
applied to it you might have to prove in
a legal context how you arrived at a
particular piece of information as a
particular time so you might have to
replay that analysis so sometimes you
may need to encapsulate the data in the
work object the analysis script the
annotations all of the outputs but this
also enables the healthcare organization
to increase organizational memory
because the person can pick up and
deconstruct how a particular job was
done and that's important to healthcare
organizations are very strapped for
analysts now let me move from that
healthcare world into the discovery side
of Health Sciences on different data
conventional cohort studies etc no
matter how high quality your studies are
usually in medicine we have a concept
space or a problem space which is much
bigger than that we can measure so our
models are often like looking through a
prism at measurement error through a
doily at concepts missingness and
measurement error so this is another
reason I need to bring in the abstract
reasoning of the investigator into the
analysis of the data in recent years we
have additional signal paths to consider
particularly through bio technologies
systems biology is proliferation of
biomarkers
putting a greater flow of differently
characterized data into this concept
space but this comes into a world where
there is very Orthodox parsimonious
approach to making a causal inference
from a set of associations extremely
cautious and rightly so it's the sitting
for associations has decades of
discipline I won't go through all of the
details but to say an association is
causal and that no gray hair doesn't
cause heart attacks is a set discipline
but that's exhausted because it's very
good at handling small numbers of
factors and we've saved out the big
important causes of ill health as
independent risk factors what we're
really interested in now in a systems
view of health are the webs of causality
to give us those bigger models of what
works together from the simple big stuff
we already know me give you an example
of taking an Orthodox approach to
epidemiology where we've applied some
less Orthodox statistical analysis with
our colleagues in Microsoft Research
well this is a population-based birth
cohort recruited mum when she's pregnant
was asked if her child to be would take
part in the study a thousand children
have been studied over now 11 years and
they're reviewed annually so that this
studies to look at asthma and allergies
measurements are some of the most
detailed in the world so unlike the
messy routine healthcare world these are
very careful measurements over a long
period the outcomes that have been
looked at or through questionnaires on
particularly respiratory symptoms very
careful tests skin prick tests blood
tests challenges to substances you
breathe in and looking at the
functioning of your lungs so controlled
measurement environment and also air
filters in the home so really strong
environmental measures
very objective blood has been collected
from these children and recently we've
extracted DNA and are about to embark
upon surgeon in genetic epidemiology as
a precursor to that here is some work
with our colleagues in Microsoft
Research to take a graphical model
probabilistic graphical model approach
to the epidemiology so rather than a few
factors we want to consider all of the
relevant factors and what I've asked
these investigators to do is to come
together and define the organizing
principle of the problem they're solving
and it wasn't asthma it's not a
diagnosis of asthma its peripheral
airway obstruction and as soon as you
got this kind of reasoning to develop to
bring out the structure that we concede
our searches of the datasets for some
wider thinking some bigger model
thinking came out we started by looking
at this silence what sensitizes you
early in life to eventually develop
asthma so this is the model we've used
so skin prick tests and blood tests to
challenges such as the house dust mite
egg pollen other substances what we've
done is to say that there is a latent
class this is something we can't measure
about sensitization and when you're
sensitized you make desensitize so not
all of these children go on to be
sensitive so we created a Markov model
across the years chaining together the
sensitization and desensitization to all
of these different substances to say is
there something more are there more
classes than the allergic child which is
what isn't currently diagnosed and this
is what comes out if we just restrict
the work to two classes and this is done
using Microsoft Internet we see a very
strong clustering of these children have
got lot red is lots of sensitization
Blue is few green is in the middle so
where there are lots of sensitization
particularly early on there's a much
greater proportion of children who
eventually page eight develop asthma
will then allow the algorithms to go in
an unsupervised way and search for more
classes and what happened then this is
what happened we separated out clusters
based on the allergens I'm on the age
the children were sensitized those who
had multiple early sensitization so a
cluster of children a class a among
these homogenous previous homogenous
group that will call the atopic child
those with lots of early sensitization
thoughts with late sensitization those
predominantly sensitive to house dust
mite and there's predominantly sensitive
to pollen and what if we relate those
clusters to the wheezing this is a
massive effect so those are lots of
early sensitization 'he's an odd ratio
of 31 compared with with the others so
there were enormous differences between
the different sensitization clusters in
who was going to develop asthma the
interesting point here is that an
unsupervised approach a machine learning
approach to the epidemiology validated a
synthesis of all of the evidence and
abstract reasoning so this made sense to
our clinical investigators and our
biologists who've been studying this for
many years and it built the model with
less investigator bias then is usually
done so we're using the data to be more
objective so usefully complex model
building what do I want out of these e
laps other some key ingredients or
clearly I want a lot of functionality
but a core component is privacy presumed
to be trusted to go in with re-signed
software anywhere near health care
record is a big job
to get in there and have to have to
expect that a group of information
system managers would do the connections
to computing resources themselves is
another big ass so we wanted visible
high-performance computing and we also
want ways that methods are so well
described that they find people
describing problems so we can get this
statistical borrowing of strength the
incorporation of a small model into a
bigger model at the point people are
reasoning about the problem and thinking
less about the process of the data
keeping their mind on what human brain
is good at making the links in abstract
between pattern here and a pattern there
with something not measured in the
middle now just give you some example
this is the UK's foresight groups that
discuss the clerk health crisis of
obesity and this is a kind of concept
map they developed oh yeah we can
you
it's not allowing me right I'm going to
force it it won't win yes it well okay
well if I could show you that there is a
massive diagram of all of the concepts
that wire together the field of obesity
into multiple subdomains and those
subdomains represent tribes of
investigators tribes of investigators
who've built small models for many years
that don't wire together around the
organizing principle of energy balance
so we get much smaller inference and
often biased inference investigator by
honest inference than we really need to
be useful so what I need is an open
unifying principle I need to build these
submodels into larger models I need easy
computation and I need my domain experts
to be reasoning an abstract to create
more complete insights to get more
reusable evidence and that is the same
challenges getting better management
across different diseases you're trying
to synthesize the evidence to make
decision for a patient if we can do that
the model should reach back to the
earlier points of of disease and we
should get better early intervention and
if that can plug into the signals we're
getting from consumer health we could
get greater citizen involvement so
overall we need to build more
realistically complex and usefully
complex models there are many common
pathways which for good common sense say
we should look across these different
domains and start building unify
graphical models but putting that
together relates not only to the deep
research but also to health policy
building it's a similar-sized
intellectual challenge and here in any
science setting we're addressing that
challenge bringing data methods and
people together
but is it really that different from the
setting that's looking at optimizing our
health care system of bringing those
lots of small models to say how do we
use a limited resource both need open
unified and unifying and usefully
complex models and I think in this
context Jim Gray's legacy may have much
wider implications thank you for
listening
yes this yes we took we took the
spreadsheets that were used in Nice
assessments as the basis for this the
spreadsheets had simple markov chains
propagating individuals from one state
to another but for those of you who are
statistical Markov models of memory
lists so that assumes that the patient
transferring from one state from after
their heart attack to their heart
failure that transition is not related
in a mathematical way to earlier
transitions such as how quickly did they
move from high blood pressure into their
first heart attack which is nonsense so
we want to extract the structure that's
what we think graphical models are very
useful if you can maintain the
reasonable structure about the Natural
History the disease and the structure of
your services then you can synthesize
the evidence with that structure and you
can add expert opinion about the
structure and about the transition
probabilities as well as simply
extracting a limited number of
transition probabilities from the
literature so it is exactly that sort of
challenge that we're addressing here for
health policy e-science if you like
and I was curious because they can be
interested in me to be very cautious
about making relationships that don't
and I'm wondering I understand the
statistical process where when you
generate about this long been wanting
more able to show us I'm just curious
how does in two ways you saw an example
of unsupervised learning from a set of
data weather factors the expert consider
we're important so rolling through that
factor space the experts would look at
different clustering and then say well
what characterizes the cluster is there
something outside the the study I've
measured so for example there's those
early sensitization late sensitization
classes of the children we may not have
measured factors but there may be a hint
of what characterizes them from few Co
variables describing them you do then
want to go measure for the next year of
follow-up of those children so that's in
the carefully measured space of building
a bigger model and being cautious about
potential confounding factors might one
of my students presented something
earlier this morning which was from
health surveys and health survey for
england is something done every every
year it's been done since 1992 measures
about 1800 variables on around twenty
thousand households so you've got a very
large set of variables and the role
there the investigator would interact
with a unified modeling approach there
too to add to emerald subsets of factors
of the search would be a round structure
that that is thought to be meaningful
building out from that but it would be a
search that's less biased than the
investigator just selecting on the basis
of their prior knowledge
so the search would use their prior
knowledge to filter but factors would be
added on a machine land basis so it's
assisted reasoning if you look yes